hey guys welcome back to the channel
today we are doing what I will call a
buzzer beater video because I'm hoping
to just get it off in time before it
gets dark and my recording looks bad uh
similarly I just took a buzzer beater
poop that one had nothing to do with the
daylight uh you guys can interpret it
yourself so I was inspired to make this
video by another good systems Design
Channel uh systems design Fight Club
that being said I do think that while I
agreed with what he did say for the most
part uh maybe I felt that he was missing
I don't know like a good quarter of the
details for the problem and so I was
hoping to amend onto this problem myself
and maybe make it a little bit more
concise anyways hope you guys enjoy all
righty so let's go ahead and get into
things basically today's video is going
to be about searching your Mutual
connections on LinkedIn so if you guys
are LinkedIn users you will know that if
you use the search bar there's an option
to basically check for your first
connection so people you're directly
connected with but then there's also an
option to actually search uh for certain
criteria for people that you're mutually
connected with so for example you can
search Mutual connections with a given
school or a given current job in this
case obviously we've got people who come
up that I'm mutually connected with who
went to Hustler's University and our
only fans creators we can see that's
karov and Trump so let's go ahead and
formalize this problem requirement
basically the gist is uh we want to be
able to search our LinkedIn for
connections where uh basically it's
going to be specifically a mutual
connection right so if this is me I have
some sort of connection I'm going to
Emmit connection search in this problem
because that's you know go to a database
and search it based on all my
connections uh the mutual connection is
one where I'm not actually connected to
them but we share a connection in common
so this is going to be a pretty
interesting problem uh another thing
that I'm going to admit from it is
actually uh not a full text search if we
did want to do a full teex search it
would just be putting everything in a
search index which we know how to do uh
but to keep things simple for now I'm
just going to say hey let's search by
like a hardcoded string for uh basically
your education or your current employer
so I'm just going to imagine those are
fields in a database and we're just
going to be using like an education
equals Cornell University for example or
something like
that cool so I am actually going to do
capacity estimates here because it's
going to become pretty relevant for a
problem like this we'll see why that is
mainly later I'm going to assume we've
got a billion users on the site that's
pretty big to assume that 1/8 of the
world is on LinkedIn may be true may not
be true but I think that's pretty
realistic for something like this I also
think that on average having each user
with 500 connections is pretty
reasonable now to be fair I am not going
to discuss very much in this video what
it would be like if a particular user
has a lot more than 500 connections
LinkedIn does cap it at some point but
I'm not sure of the exact number and
it's definitely higher than 500 that
being said they do stop showing the
number at 500 so it's hard for me to say
exactly uh this problem would be pretty
interesting if you could have you know
50,000 connections each it would
actually be quite a bit harder and
you'll see why in a little bit so what
this means is that on on average each
user basically has 25,000 Mutual
connections right because each of your
500 connections also has 500 connections
now it's true that we can have some
overlap there but that's why I say
something like on average cool each
search preview so you know when we show
a search preview when doing our actual
search over here we're not showing their
full profile we're just showing a few
Fields about them so I'm going to assume
that that contains around a kilobyte of
data which I think if anything is
probably more than it actually is but
again let's make this problem as hard as
we can for ourselves and also my last
assumption is that each user is going to
update their you know education or their
current employer on average once per
year so if we have a billion users that
means we've got a billion updates per
year meaning that we've got around 3
million updates per day this is all
going to be relevant in a little bit
cool so the first thing that I want to
discuss is basically the Paradigm of
thinking of this problem as a graph
problem so let's imagine you're right
here your Mutual connections are anyone
who is basically a second degreee Edge
from you but isn't also a first-degree
Edge right so like for example if I drew
an edge between me and this guy over
here he's my connection he's also my
Mutual connection but he doesn't really
count as a mutual connection for this
problem we're going to assume that he's
just a connection right so basically we
would be looking for all nodes at a
distance of two connections from you and
basically this doesn't include the ones
that are reached in one Edge so really
the way that we would do this is just by
running a depth first search you would
stop after you've reached a recursion
depth of two and then you could use some
shared hashmap in that depth for search
that basically allows you to see whether
you've touched a given node or not so
that's simple enough I guess the
question now is what technology would we
actually use in practice to do something
like this well perhaps we would use
something like a graph database now I've
talked about these plenty on the channel
but just for a quick refresher basically
there are two types of graph databases
there's the non-native ones think of
this as like a SQL table where you have
one table solely devoted to the edges
between two nodes in the graph so in
this case we could call that a
connections table right and what this is
saying is hey there's an edge between
user two and user three there's an edge
between user 2 and user 6 there's an
edge between user 3 and user two and so
on and so on and because we can put an
index on this first column now I can say
if I want to do some sort of traversal
okay well first I can jump to user 3 let
me now go find user 3 in this index oh
he's over here oh now we're jumping to
user 12 let me go find user 12 in this
index oh he's over here now the problem
with that is as this connections table
gets bigger because we're using an index
here what it effectively means is that
we're binary searching this connections
table in order to find our next node and
so that means that as the connections
table gets bigger that binary search
takes longer and longer in fact it grows
in logarithmic time relative to the
number of connections so that's why
non-native graph databases handle graph
data sets pretty slow on the contrary
native graph databases will actually
Traverse edges in O of one the the
reason being that for a given person or
a given node over here I can actually
put the physical location on dis of who
they're connected to so now basically
this pointer is going to point me to
user 3 on disk user 3 has a pointer
that's going to point me back to user
two and so on and so on and so on now
that's not to say that this is going to
be particularly fast even if a native
graph database is going to be faster
than a non-native one the problem there
is that at the end of the day we're
still doing a ton of random seeks on
disk right drives are typically meant to
be accessing contiguous data where we
have good spatial locality however when
we're jumping around like this all the
time it is still going to be pretty slow
as if that was an issue enough however
we have another which is going to be
partitioning right so ideally when we're
making a query to a database we want to
typically write to one partition and we
want to read to one partition so it' be
great if we had some sort of LinkedIn
connection graph that looks like this
right where we've got one cluster of
people who are all interconnected
however then we also have another
cluster of people that are all
interconnected but they don't relate to
one another and then we can separate
them on different partitions this would
be nice because say I wanted to find all
the mutual connections of this guy right
here I only have to look at this
partition I know there's no chance that
I also have to read this partition
however in reality the LinkedIn social
graph is probably highly connected right
in reality we can see that it's very
intertwined over here and there's not
really any good way to split it up such
that if I want to find the mutual
connections for for this guy I can only
read one partition now that is going to
be a
problem like I mentioned we're super Inc
connected uh interconnected so it's hard
to partition well because there's no
clear place to basically split out our
partitions so now all of a sudden if I
make a connection right in my database
let's say I want to connect this guy
here to this guy here and they're on
different partitions now I basically
have to make an edge on both of those
partitions it has to involve a two-phase
commit and some sort of Lock and that is
going to be problematic and especially
if I want to basically find you know
let's say I have another partition over
here and this guy is connected over here
and these guys are connected now I have
to potentially read multiple partitions
to find all of my guy over here's uh
Mutual connections and so that is going
to get very annoying it's going to get
very slow it's going to get even slower
if we want consistent reads from every
single partition because then we
probably have to grab locks on many of
those different nodes but that's a top a
topic for a whole different
discussion cool so what can we do
instead because the graph database
likely is not going to be too feasible
for us here well what we could do is
actually basically just cach every
single results for all of our users also
I'm very sorry that I keep fat fingering
the screen today I don't know what's
happening so we want to keep our reads
as fast as possible and the only way to
basically do that is to pre-organize for
every single user all of their Mutual
connections now this is an arduous
process because it means that we
basically have to say every single time
there's a connection load all of the
users new Mutual connections so we
basically have to do a bunch of fan out
but we'll talk about that in a second so
let's say there's a billion users each
one of them has 255,000 Mutual
connections and each one of those kind
of rows takes one kilobyte to store we
have to store 25 pedabytes of data now
that is objectively a pretty obscene
amount of data it is storable there are
many companies of LinkedIn size that do
do things like this but it means we're
going to need a lot of partitions so the
question is how should we partition this
thing well we should probably Shard by
our user ID right because for one user
ID I basically want to know hey who are
all these Mutual connections that they
have and access them all on just one
database because what we really care
about here is making this read path as
fast as humanly possible as humanly
possible and so the way that we can also
do this as well is by denormalizing the
profile data per Mutual connection right
it's not enough to just say hey this guy
is user ID 4 this guy is user ID 6 and
this guy user ID 8 Because the actual
profile data for all three of these guys
could live on a bunch of different
database nodes and then we find
ourselves doing a large distributed join
and a scatter gather query and that's
probably going to be too expensive so
ideally instead of doing that what we
want are actual connection names we've
got person a who went to school
a and works at company
a and so on and so on and so on and
denormalize that quite a bit so of
course that is going to complicate
things too so let's actually look at how
our mutual cache table might look like I
started to touch upon this a second ago
so ideally we've got the following
schema we've got our user ID right so
this is a user who we want to fetch all
of their Mutual connections for we've
got all of their Mutual connection IDs
so for user ID 3 over here we can see
that they have a mutual connection of
number seven user 7 and user 10 and
again because we're denormalizing data
we can actually store their name their
school and their company so that's what
we've gone head and done in order to
quickly find all of these for a given
user ideally we want to be indexed on
our user ID another thing that we could
do is within that actual user ID index
we could come up with a couple of
secondary indexes uh particularly local
ones because Global ones can get very
expensive on rights but uh we can do
local secondary indices on things like
the name the school and the company so
that we can quickly find those when
we're querying for them right if I want
to query for all results for user ID 3
where one of their Mutual connections
went to Harvard having an index field on
uh the school is going to make that a
lot simpler and quite a bit faster
because now I can binary
search great uh in terms of the database
Choice uh I just went ahead and said
let's use a SQL database we don't really
care if the rights to this thing are
fast we're optimizing for our read path
and so again it's going to be nice to
have a B+ tree it's going to be nice to
be able to read from a single node as
opposed to using something like
Cassandra where we might have Quorum
consistency and then have to read from
multiple noes noes at once cool so what
does it actually look like now when we
add a connection because this is where
things get complicated well basically
let's say we've got a user over here and
he connects uh with a new person right
so let's say this is user 10 and he
accepts a connection from user 15 right
so now we have 1015 now this piece over
here this first piece is optional but
you could have some sort of like
connections LED your database just to
perform change data capture on or you
could cancel that out and just throw it
right in Kafka which is ultimately what
I'm going to do at the end but the point
is we're putting the entry 1015 in Kafka
right we've got some new
connection now the first thing that's
going to happen is we're going to
receive this by a stateless consumer now
note that uh I technically need to add
10 comma 15 to our database but also I
probably want to add 15 comma 10 the
reason being that we want to eventually
have some sort of connections
database for first-degree connections
and we want to be able to Shard that by
user
ID and so ultimately we're going to have
to add both of those rows uh so that
they can go in both of the appropriate
chards so in order to avoid having to
make two wrs at once and do a two-phase
commit we can put it in Kofa once we can
receive it in some stateless consumer
right over here and then we can split
that right into two now because this
thing is in Kafka means that the message
is replayable we're not going to lose it
and so this is going to make our thing a
lot more fault tolerant while basic
basically ensuring that we have eventual
consistency without requiring any
two-phase commit or any Saga commit or
anything like that so now this is
basically going to sync this message
both to the partition that's responsible
for handling connections for user 10 and
the partition that's responsible for
handling connections for user 15 we'll
probably use some hash function to
determine this in reality so this is now
going to flow through Kafka and wouldn't
you expect it here it is Flink so what
do we do on our Flink notes well
basically we have a running tally of all
of that user connections cached in
memory and that's not going to be a lot
of data because at the end of the day
it's going to be like a 500 element list
or something like that which is not a
lot so in this case user 10 we're adding
uh element 15 to it and in the case of
user 15 we've just connected and now
added element 10 to the end of our list
so now we have to go ahead and do the
following we want to modify all of our
mutual connection databases so that we
can quickly update all of our users
Mutual connections so for user 10 what's
happening well basically if user 10 and
user 15 were already Mutual connections
of one another we basically want to be
able to ensure that they are no longer
Mutual connections same thing with user
15 like I mentioned we need to do this
twice for both of those because at the
end of the day uh we are basically
keeping track of this for all users and
so we need to remove them as Mutual
connections of one another now note that
user 3 was already connected to user 10
which means that user 15 was incoming is
now a mutual connection of it right
because it goes three
to 10 these guys are connected and now
we also have 15 which is also connected
to it so that's why we insert 3 comma 15
like I said everything is symmetric here
we also have to insert 15 comma 3 note
that user 4 was also connected with user
10 so now I have to insert 4 comma 15
insert 15 comma 4 and then on the other
side of this note that 8 was connected
to user 15 which means that 8 and 10 are
now Mutual connections and 10 and 8 are
symmetric right so all in all basically
this is on the order of O of n Plus and
rights so keep in mind that because M
and N are basically the number of
connections that each of the two newly
connected users have this means that
basically we're probably going to have a
thousand or a couple thousand rights
every single time two users connect now
that's a lot but at the end of the day
it is feasible right we see Twitter do
this for its fan out on tweets all the
time it's not unreasonable to actually
make 1,000 rights per connection because
it's all being done asynchronously in
the background and no one's waiting on
this we can basically do it pretty
slowly and we can afford to do so so
that's totally fine of course all of
these rights are going to go through a
load balancer which is probably
listening to zookeeper somewhere letting
everyone know what databases handle what
key range right user ID you know X to y
or something like that and then of
course that way we can send the rights
to the correct
Place cool now let's go ahead and talk
about profile updates so like I
mentioned we basically denormalized all
of our data so it's not really good
enough to just have user IDs available
because as I mentioned we would have to
fetch all of their profiles every time
we were doing a read and so we opt to
denormalize instead because we want to
avoid this scatter gather query so the
question is basically for connections
what we've done is we've taken new
connections we've put them in flank and
then we' fanned them out to the database
node that they need to go to so again
we're doing M plus n wres where M and N
are the number of connections that each
of those two newly connected users have
the problem is for Mutual connections
right because when someone updates their
profile they basically have a bunch of
mutual connections right we said on
average around 25,000 so if a user has n
connections uh really they're going to
have n uh times probably n connections
so n squ but the reality is just you
know they have however many Mutual
connections that they do based on uh the
connection graph so around 25,000 wres
now a couple thousand was okay I think
25 5,000 it starts to get pretty
excessive and it's probably not so
feasible especially for people who have
a lot more than 25,000 Mutual
connections this is really starting to
be Overkill so it's probably going to be
too expensive to do a fan out of all of
our profile updates to all three you
know not just all three but all
partitions of these Mutual connection
databases over on our left so what can
we do instead well this is where some of
our capacity estimates are going to come
in so like I mentioned recall there's a
billion people people who use our
service uh they all update their profile
once a year so that means on average
there's probably going to be around 3
million profile updates per day each of
them with size 1 kilobyte that we have
to store in our uh Mutual connection
databases cool so basically the gist is
this is equal to 3 GB of memory which is
not actually so much when you think
about it it's pretty reasonable so what
we want to do instead is rather than
basically um you know Fanning out all of
our rights the second that they're made
we can actually batch them together
right we can cache this in memory on a
few servers and then eventually we'll go
into this in the next slide but we can
upload them in a batch to all of our
mutual connection databases so let's say
I make a right to my profile database
I've just changed something of course we
can use derived data Kafka over here and
then snc it all of our changes for the
day into memory because it's only 3 GB
that is very handleable so these are our
profile Chang caches what are we
actually going to do with those well we
can use a batch job so the gist is once
per day we have 3 GB of data that we
need to send over to all of our database
instances and say Hey you now have to
update all of your denormalized data to
reflect these profile changes so we can
basically run some sort of script a
batch job a Cron job anything like that
and the gist is because all of this data
is cached in memory it should be fairly
easy to basically convert it into a
format that uh we can easily upload to
to our database cool so basically uh you
know any of these Mutual connection
databases either via a stored procedure
or via script can fetch all of the
profile changes very quickly and update
their relevant rows cool another thing
that would be nice is that we don't
actually need to lock all of our rows in
our mutual connections table over here
the reason being that uh you know you
only really need to lock all of your
rows when you're making a batch
insertion if you care about uh making
consistent reads meaning that you want
to see the database in a consistent
State and not between a transaction but
we don't really care about that right
it's fine if uh you know I basically
have some of my rights that are
completed others that are not and then a
user happens to search in between them
you can just grab the lock for the row
that you're editing at a time not a huge
deal so what does this actually look
like in reality well let's say we have
some mutuals table right we've got user
four over here and his mutuals are
Donald Trump and Joe Biden and you've
got user six who has the mutuals of
Donald Trump and Barack Obama so you can
see that Donald Trump is repeated but
the point is we're only going to send
the Donald Trump Row from our cash over
to the database once and then we'll do
something like a hash join where
basically you know you would make a hash
table indexed on the user ID of Donald
Trump and that way you can do one linear
scan through this database look if
there's any data that needs to be
replaced and replace it accordingly so
as you can see Joe Biden is going to
replace this one row over here Donald
Trump is going to replace these two rows
over here and by doing this once a day
we can basically ensure that we're not
making thousands of Rights we're just
making one really big batch right at the
end of the day to all of our partitions
and since this cache is relatively small
we can basically just broadcast all of
that data over to the database it's not
like it has to be done in a particular
way we don't have to Shard anything
super fancy we can basically just do
this incrementally on some sort of
schedule okay let us go ahead and tie
everything together
so on our left we have a
client I already went through what
happens when a client makes a new
connection but let's go ahead and get
started over here so when a client makes
a new connection the first thing that we
can do is put that connection in Kafka
the reason is we just want to put it in
there once so we don't have to do a
two-phase commit we then have a
stateless consumer right it doesn't need
to maintain any state so it doesn't have
to be flank or anything like that it can
be any old server that just listens to
Kafka all it's going to do is see a
message like 10 to 15
send it into the Q for both 10 and send
it into the Q for both 15 so let's say
this is the Q for user 10 this is the Q
for user 15 this is the case because we
shed on the hash of our user ID we can
use something like consistent hashing to
make sure that the load on all these Q
should be relatively even from there we
have Flink Flink is basically going to
maintain a
mapping
maintain
mapping from
user to
connections the reason that we want to
maintain this mapping from a user to
their connections is so that when we see
an incoming connection we can very
quickly find out who all of their new
Mutual connections are so now we have a
bunch of different operations right
we've just figured out hey both of these
guys have a bunch of new Mutual
connections let's go ahead and put those
in our mutual connection
database which of course is going to be
both charted and indexed on our user ID
so that if I want to say find all of my
Mutual connections uh or find all of
user 4's Mutual connections I can do so
very easily and I only have to read from
one single node great now let's go ahead
and talk about the profile editing
service because since we've denormalized
all of this data we have to go ahead and
figure out how we can update those
profiles on some sort of interval like I
mentioned fan out is probably going to
be too expensive here it's just going to
lead to too many rights because we
basically have to do a right per Mutual
connection every time you update your
profile which is infeasible instead
we're better off doing this in a batch
so we do our profile edit over here at
the profile edit service that's going to
go into the profile database because
ultimately we do need to store this
somewhere the profile database will
probably have a more complete model of
uh the profile where it's not just your
school and your current employer but you
know all of your past employers maybe
some image data about you something like
that I think my SQL should be pretty
sufficient here because uh we mostly
care about our read speeds we're not
writing to this table nearly as often
and by sharding and indexing on user ID
we can make sure that these guys have a
fairly even distribution of Rights and
same goes for reads cool then we go
ahead and use change data capture to
sync those updates into Kafka and
furthermore cach them all in our profile
edit caches then using some sort of
daily batch job whether it is basically
a stored procedure on all of these
databases on the right or just these
guys directly querying to the databases
via some sort of crown job we can go
ahead and push all of the data right to
the databases and up uh update them in
place this is going to be really useful
because then when we do eventually hit
our mutual search service sure we have
eventual consistency as far as the
profile updates go but I'd say 99% of
the time if not more you're going to see
up-to-date
data the way that we would go ahead and
fetch our data for a mutual search
service is say you know let's say we
want to see it for user 4 that's going
to hit our load balancer over here it's
going to Route us to the correct
database node we're going to run our
query on this particular node and then
of course we're going to return all of
our data right here and back to our user
well guys I hope you found this video to
be useful and informative uh I think the
trick with uh the batch update on the
mutual connection databases was pretty
cool we haven't really gotten to see
something like that used before uh but
when you know there are small enough
Deltas for your updates you can actually
do that option not everything has to be
done streaming sometimes streaming is
too expensive and you have to resort to
using a bat shop anyways hope you have a
great day and I will see you in the next
one